three two one
mankind and the elements
for some
it's an uncomfortable bond
for others when weather strikes
inspiration begins you come to a place
like this
the stars just burst
these are the people who challenge
nature
seek out its limits
reveal its secrets
and embrace its awesome power
in this episode we'll meet a group of
civilians putting their lives at risk to
rescue people trapped in iceland's
extreme environments when you get called
out your heart goes pounding almost out
of your chest a man who climbs hundreds
of feet in the air in the hopes of
protecting some of the oldest trees on
earth
and a team of sailors racing up the
treacherous coastline of the pacific
northwest
yeah we're uh we're really scared these
pioneers are the great outdoors ahead
and that's amazing
[Music]
the moment right before i jump
there's a split second there where
everything goes completely silent
[Music]
and that's when i push off the edge
three two
one
we have all wanted to fly
but who would willingly throw themselves
off a mountain my name is ellen brennan
and i'm a wing suit base jumper
currently i'm the fastest flying woman
in the world when it comes to wing suit
base jumping
a wing suit is a special suit that
inflates with air and allows you to in
essence fly
or glide
ellen does this all over the world at
crazy speeds on average i'm flying about
180 190 kilometers per hour that's
almost 120 miles an hour
so when i'm going to go do a jump i'm
focusing on what's happening
weather-wise i'm looking at the trees to
see if there's wind blowing i'm watching
the sun to see if it's heating up the
air i don't want to push my luck with
the mountain
my vision is the first thing i noticed
but everything becomes very focused on
just my feet
my heart's beating super fast it's
usually beating like 160 170 beats per
minute
sometimes people will talk to me and i
won't even hear them
as soon as i push off i can hear the
slip of my feet off of the rocks
[Music]
like it's something that shouldn't
happen it's not natural
but i'm doing it
how in the world do i get to be able to
do that
one of the coolest things in the world
like that can't be anything better to
do it's pretty mind-blowing
in the dangerous seas of the pacific
northwest
44 sailboats are competing in one of the
longest and most grueling human powered
races on earth
the race to alaska is a 750 mile journey
and the only way forward is by wind or
by ore
here the water and weather conditions
are extremely unpredictable if you get
stuck in them
you're on your own
it's getting worse out here guys we have
to go to bellabella
i don't think there's any other sport
that relies
so heavily on the weather to propel you
but you also have to respect it
otherwise it will
destroy you
spencer weber is with team hot mess a
crew of four young canadians with little
endurance sailing experience they're
racing against faster boats with more
seasoned crews in a sale contest that
knocks out more than half the teams that
attempt it
so for these intrepid young sailors it's
not about winning it's about making it
to the finish line in one piece
[Music]
race to alaska is a 750 mile engineless
unsupported boat race from port townsend
washington to ketchikan alaska and
there's only two checkpoints in between
you have to go through see more narrows
and you have to go through bella bella
but other than that it's choose your own
adventure the race is really
unconventional because sailing has so
many rules so we wanted to strip it all
away and make it about just any boat no
handicaps or anything and if you can
make it first you get ten thousand
dollars
there's a lot of different battles going
on in the r2ak fellow racers who you're
trying to compete with but you're also
trying to overcome these enormous
forces of nature wind and current and
you're just in this tiny little boat
trying to take on these challenges head
on
team hot mess are well aware of the
dangers inherent with sailing in the
pacific northwest
they train for the race in nearby
vancouver british columbia so we had
four crew it was myself neil roberts
will schwanger and nick swanger we met
here and decided to do the race together
i was a civil engineer
in the middle of a quarter life crisis
and it was between staying in my cozy
cubicle or
going on a
sufferfest to alaska so i decided to go
to alaska
anyone who tells you they're doing it
for the 10 grand is lying because the
guys who are going to win it are doing
it in hydrofoiling carbon fiber
fancy boats
and to them 10 grand is just chump
change for me i just love sailing and
the r2ak seemed like the steepest
learning curve around
three
two
one
the race start was at noon and
everyone's sprinting down the docks to
their boat jumping on the boat untying
it and then everyone's using their cuban
propulsion method to get out of the
harbor so everyone's rowing and pedaling
and paddling as quickly as they can to
get out
the adrenaline's going and everyone's
super stoked and the atmosphere is just
wild sales are up around the corner
we're finally racing to the left boys
rounded the point out of victoria
harbour there was awesome wind all right
first transition zone
oh yeah we're sailing now
[Music]
when you get further north you have a
great deal of current that wind against
tide condition can cause standing waves
it will be very difficult for these
vessels to try and get through
that area of the coast as soon as we
round to chatham point and enter
johnston straight the gaels picked up
you know we have like 35 knots on the
nose and we're like bashing through all
these standing waves and we have a
pretty light boat so we were getting
some like hang time off waves it was
making all kinds of crazy sounds
and then once you get through the john
stone straight you're going up the
outside of bc
then you're in open ocean and that
presents its own challenges massive
swells and no shelter from wind and you
feel so alone it's it's really humbling
especially when a storm starts ripping
through
[Music]
the forecast was for 35
to 40 knots and we were seeing like
maybe five
to like seven knots we didn't listen to
the weather forecast and just got
slammed by 35 knots of wind
yeah we're uh we're really scared right
now so we turned around and now we're
trying to find somebody's dock or
something but nobody lives here
there's not a lot of docks
it was driving rain big waves and you
couldn't see your hand in front of your
face it was so dark there were no lights
on land we had no idea where anything
was we couldn't anchor because we
brought in sufficient anchor gear so we
just had to like keep sailing around in
in circles until daylight basically
getting caught that night before it was
a bit of an eye-opener from there on we
kind of like took the forecast a lot
more seriously we mapped out a bunch of
bailout points so if we'd have to stop
we knew on the map like where we could
go
[Music]
coming in to catch again
oh my god looking forward to being dry
oh yeah
you know we've been in our dry suits for
24 hours straight and everyone's wet and
cold and tired and then the wind just
completely shut off
you're paddling into the finish line of
this epic race that you've just done it
was super anticlimactic but the race
isn't about the money and it's not about
the finish line it's about the journey
there couldn't be a more poetic end to
the race to alaska than a brutal hate
mission to the finish line
i would definitely do the race again
you kind of need this like blind
optimism to get through it and the
ability to
forget pain and suffering
[Music]
on the sandy shores of the florida keys
sea turtles are laying their eggs
but a threat is looming for these gentle
creatures
the caribbean climate has become
increasingly unpredictable
as rising sea levels [ __ ] the beaches
where these turtles annually nest
they come back to their natal beaches
so animals that were born here are
coming back to this very little spit of
land in order to lay their own eggs
if the beach goes away they may not be
as flexible to use another beach
dr kristen hart and her team of
researchers are working around the clock
tagging and tracking these turtles in an
effort to protect their future
they're imperiled they do need help and
we're trying to figure out you know
where the problems are
we are here on east key in dry tortugas
national park
we are about 70 miles west of key west
and we're in the gulf of mexico
there's seven islands we are on one of
the smallest but one of the densest
turtle nesting beaches some of them are
right on top of each other a foot away
from each other
this is a almost completely marine park
and the turtles come up and grace us
with their presence
it's pretty amazing to see these animals
up close and personal with them and we
get you know right in there
generally sea turtles date back to the
time of the dinosaurs so it's 200
million years of evolution
our study was the first to really
concentrate on the dry tortugas turtles
our goals are to try to determine
patterns of movement and habitat use to
figure out where they might go
all these points are either sightings or
capture points
when we first started working here we
realized that we could dip net juvenile
green turtles i had done this in the
everglades and out here the water is
much more clear we can pursue them in
the flats and shallower areas
coming up
the bigger turtles out here we do what's
called rodeo capture or also turtle
jumping
they're usually 10 or 15 feet down but
when they need to come get a breath
they're coming up to the surface and so
that's when the diver meets them down
there
you basically get your hands sort of on
the rear and right behind the head and
you get the animal pointed up
it's a team effort once we get them on
board the boat we'll do a standard
workup which includes measuring them
weighing them taking blood samples
tissue samples
there's a lot of questions that we can
ask even just about how healthy they are
and how healthy then are the resources
that they're using
we also fix devices on them to track
their movements so we've used acoustic
telemetry radio telemetry and then
satellite tracking
so we're learning a lot about their
movement paths and their their areas of
residence
[Music]
they've been around the globe but
they're hardwired to come back to the
very place where they were born to lay
their own eggs
[Music]
if an animal was born on east key she'll
come back to his key she's not going to
go use loggerhead key or one of the
other keys here
[Music]
we all take turns every 30 minutes
walking around this beach in particular
takes about 10 minutes to walk around
if they nest we let them nest and mark
off where the nest is and then we work
her up just like the same workup we
would do with a little turtle
she's corralled in a box because they
can be 400 pounds and they're very
powerful
they'll do that about every two weeks
during a season when i get recaptures
that's really exciting because you know
the animal still survived wherever she
went
in order for turtles to lay their eggs
the conditions have to be just right
ideally they'll encounter high tides
dark beaches and warm sea surface
temperatures
otherwise they'll do something called a
false crawl in which a turtle will make
their way onto the beach only to turn
back around
we don't know really why they false
crawl but something isn't right
maybe they're not feeling contractions
maybe the conditions just aren't right
at that spot maybe they dig and they hit
a piece of a coral or a root or
something like that
and false crawls could become more
frequent
rising sea levels reduce the amount of
available beach space
and rising temperatures can drastically
affect scent temperature
studies show that cooler nest
temperatures produce more males
while warmer nests generally produce
females
with sea level rise in climate change
they're threatened i think we're a
little more concerned about their
trajectory of their population because
it's generally not good for the turtle
[Music]
we've learned a lot about these dry
tortugas turtles and it really is
valuable to me to to know that they
value the research that we're
contributing we're answering questions
that are important that haven't been
asked before
it's definitely demanding but at the
same time i think it's one of the most
rewarding things we could ever do
there aren't many people allowed on this
little patch of land so i feel very
privileged to be able to to play a role
in you know figuring these turtles out
and being in this very special place
italy's mount aetna is one of the most
active volcanoes in the world
it erupts nearly every year spewing lava
and clouds of ash
but for claudio lanza family the black
powder is an untapped adventure
my name is claudio and i ski over
volcanoes
i have been skiing since i was four
years old
i spent most part of the year close to
the mountain
when i spend time away from it i feel
nostalgic like
something is missing to my soul to my
life and in this moment i take my ski
and i go up
[Music]
mount titan is located on the east coast
of sicily
[Music]
is known as the tallest and active
vulcan in the europe
the risks to climbing mount etna are the
same of any other mountain
you have to be careful and
respect what's surrounding us
[Music]
the view from the top is unique you can
see the landscape changing many times
from green woods
to desert volcanic area
all the lava flow and the coast
[Music]
[Applause]
black powder is a volcanic sand and it's
format during the eruption
[Applause]
it's incredible
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
siggy ron hillmarsson is an icelandic
baker
with an unconventional oven
he bakes bread by baring it underground
where it's heated for 24 hours by nearby
hot springs
it's very common to see hot springs here
in iceland there is constant lava
crawling under us
this lava is heating up water and this
water comes boiling up on the surface
we could put it in the oven but this is
much more fun
iceland is one of the most volcanic
regions in the world with 30 active
volcanoes at any one time
that helps create an abundance of hot
springs
some with boiling hot water
and siggy uses them to his advantage
he specializes in baking hoove abroad a
traditional icelandic rye bread recipe
that dates back hundreds of years
i know for sure that in this village
i can track it down as far as late 1800s
something
my grandmother taught my mother how to
bake this bread
and my mother taught me
in
the hot spring rye bread recipe we have
rye flour sugar baking powder salt and
milk we put this in a pot we put butter
in the pot then we
wrap it with plastic foil and we put it
down in our hot spring hole for 24 hours
[Music]
it's very obvious to see if the ground
is hot or not
i never use a thermometer if i need to
check the heat i just use this one
our biggest challenge is rain if it
rains a lot these holes that we are
using can cool down
and if they are not hot enough obviously
the bread doesn't bake completely
[Music]
everybody eats our bread our visitors
the locals hot spring rye bread has a
unique taste that you don't get from
ovens
the texture of this bread is quite
special it's quite heavy it's not the
typical light bread
when you show this to travelers that
come to iceland and you see their faces
they go wow
then you start to think that this is
quite amazing actually
[Music]
there's lots of amazing weather
phenomenon happening all over our planet
but what's going on outside of our
atmosphere
my name is leland melvin and as an
astronaut i can tell you weather
conditions in space can be a matter of
life and death
especially during a spacewalk
[Music]
when we prepare for a spacewalk we have
to be able to deal with temperatures
that range from positive 250 degrees
fahrenheit in the sun
and minus 250 degrees in the shade
[Music]
but in our spacesuit we have the ability
to withstand those temperature extremes
because we have visors that reflect the
sun away from our eyes and we have
heated gloves as well as a heated suit
and then we have cooling that allows us
to stay cool during those temperature
extremes
[Music]
a solar flare is a sudden flash of
brightness observed near the sun's
surface that emits x-ray and uv
radiation
in space the radiation levels can be
deadly
when we're notified of a solar flare on
the space station we retreat to what we
call the doghouse this doghouse is lined
with water bags that allow us to block
the radiation coming from the sun before
it gets to our bodies and that's where
we go to keep from getting exposed to
high energy radiation
as we go further out into our solar
system
weather events become more and more
extreme
[Music]
jupiter our solar system's biggest
planet also features its most impressive
storm the great red spot
the gigantic tempest is twice as wide as
planet earth and has winds that reach up
to 400 miles per hour
it's been swirling over jupiter for at
least 150 years
further out neptune features its own
great big storm it takes up the planet's
entire atmosphere
neptune is our solar system's windiest
planet
with wind speeds that can reach up to
1500 miles per hour
that's nine times faster than the
strongest winds ever recorded on earth
to find the strongest known winds in our
universe
we have to go well beyond our solar
system
astrophysicists at york university have
discovered the fastest winds ever
recorded near a supermassive black hole
these wind speeds clock in at 125
million miles per hour
i hope my crew never gets caught up in
anything like that
known as the land of fire and ice
iceland is an island of extremes where
people wage a relentless war against the
elements
it's seriously unpredictable weather
it's basically like a battle zone of
different
high pressure low pressure areas
anything can happen
dangerous conditions mean people can
find themselves in serious trouble and
in need of rescue but there's a problem
the small country has no army or
government program to help
so citizens form the icelandic search
and rescue team known as icesar a
national emergency force
they're everyday people
willing to risk their lives to save
others in the worst conditions
imaginable
you're going out in the conditions when
everyone else is supposed to be inside
so you have to be a little bit crazy but
in a good way
isar is a community of volunteers that
responds to calls for help all year
round in iceland
i think to take part in isar you just
have to be willing to put forward the
skills that you have i sometimes
consider a rescue team like a village
you need every kind of person to make
everything work
i think it's kind of amazing because
it's all volunteers
we have professors taxi drivers
carpenters plumbers
office workers
just name it men and women
all kinds of people
it's very hard to imagine iceland
without our association and our teams
[Music]
iceland's breathtaking landscape
attracts tourists and adventure seekers
from all over the world
but that beauty can lure people to a
false sense of security
the weather conditions can change
faster than anything else you can have a
sunny day and in two minutes it's a
storm
wind rain even snow in the summertime
people are just going for a hike and
they're pretty confident that the
mountain that they're going on is not
dangerous
[Music]
we have the lower glaciers which have
become quite a popular tourist
attraction and people are going for
walks on these and they are full of
crevasses extremely dangerous super
slippery
and then they fall over and hurt
themselves then they have to rely on
search and rescue to come and find them
for average citizens to gain the skills
needed to be part of isar they go
through a rigorous 18-month training
program
they learn mountaineering climbing and
orienteering
it takes a huge skill set but
when you can't deal with any weather
then you can go out and help people
[Music]
across the whole country i think our
teams get 4.5 callouts per day
and our people are running from their
own work or their family to join the
team
when i get called out we have three
codes it's f1 high priority
live in stake
f2 not as high priority and f3 easy
going
when you get called out high priority
and you get your text and it says a
child then your heart goes pounding
almost out of your chest and you run out
i don't even say goodbye to my children
or wife
[Music]
i can remember one call a boy got lost
in television all i could think about
was my son
if he got lost i would like to have
everyone helping so
a lot of emotions comes up when you get
called out
i'm proud of the unity and the fact that
people are willing to sacrifice their
spare time
to help others
the feeling that i get when we rescue
someone it doesn't have to be me that
finds the person can be another group
searching somewhere else but we're
searching for the same person when
someone gets found you get this wellness
feeling we did something right
they are our heroes in in so many ways
but in icelandic culture we don't do a
lot of hero talk
no i'm not a hero i'm just a part of a
team
i'm not a hero now
i'm just a normal person
i'm very proud of the association and
what they have accomplished
they've saved a lot of lives
[Music]
california's iconic sequoias are the
largest trees on earth
these giants have lived for thousands of
years
surviving war
famine and the rise of globalization
but california's ongoing drought could
mean disaster
these enormous trees are already showing
signs of weakness never seen before
anthony ambrose and a team of
researchers are heading into the forest
to climb hundreds of feet in the air and
see what can be done to save these
magnificent trees
[Music]
sequoia national park is just absolutely
amazing
a giant sequoia is the largest tree on
the planet
and they have these huge orange trunks
and massive sprawling crowns that have
huge limbs some of the branches are five
six feet thick they live to be more than
three thousand years old
i'm fascinated with how they grow and
how they are able to get to be so old
and so big
it's just an amazing experience to be
able to study them so intimately and so
closely
california is currently in the middle of
a severe drought
the giant sequoia trees appear to be
showing some symptoms
of some drought stress
more stress than we've ever measured in
giant sequoia trees
and we want to know why
[Music]
our research entails climbing the giant
sequoia trees
and
measuring their water status basically
an index of how stressed they are
relative to
the environment the water status of all
plants is kind of like the equivalent of
blood pressure in that human it's just a
basic measure of
how much water they have
available to them to continue
to function and grow
[Music]
so we clip little shoots of foliage and
put them in this device that is able to
measure how much
tension the water column is at at the
time that you cut that little piece of
foliage
we put the little piece of foliage leaf
end down into this pressurized chamber
and the amount of pressure it takes to
push the water back out of the stem is
equal to the amount of tension it was
under when you cut that piece of foliage
when water availability declines such as
during a drought that creates a lot more
tension in the tree
when the tension becomes too great
then tiny little air bubbles form in the
wood and when it gets bad enough then
the plant suffers and starts to die
[Music]
there's a couple reasons why we need to
climb to the tops of these trees
[Music]
as water moves up the tree it's fighting
gravity and friction and the top of the
tree is going to be the most stressed
part of the tree so in order to get a
really good idea of
how stressed they are we need to go to
the very tippy top
[Music]
it's a really humbling experience
because you're up in the crown of these
massive ancient things and they make you
feel small
i'm at the top of a very large giant
sequoia tree we're waiting for the
sunrise because it's really really
pretty this morning
in order to get a really good
understanding of how the trees are
responding to the drought we need to
understand different
time periods we climb up into the giant
sequoia trees at the predawn hours
before the sun rises and measure their
water status kind of at their most
relaxed state when they're not losing
water to the atmosphere
and then we also go back in the middle
of the day when they're the most active
and most stressed and measure their
water status and collect leaf samples at
that point as well
[Laughter]
[Music]
giant sequoias really need fire it's a
natural part of the ecosystem here they
can use this information to prioritize
where they do prescribe burning to be
able to thin out some of the understory
trees that are competing for the water
and hopefully provide more water to the
large giant sequoia trees
[Music]
it's important to realize and remember
that these trees have been living for
thousands of years and they've dealt
with pretty severe events fires and
droughts in the past and they're
amazingly resilient one of the things
that really is remarkable about these
trees is their ability to recover from
drought type events
the question is as conditions change as
temperatures continue to increase
globally
our condition is going to change to a
point where they may reach some
threshold where they're not able to
recover from these type of events
it's an absolutely amazing unique
experience to be able to climb into
these trees we want to preserve them we
want them to be here and we want them to
be healthy and happy
[Music]
it's a surprisingly dangerous mission
safely navigate the skies of one of the
most iconic tourist destinations in
america
the helicopter pilots of niagara falls
battle extreme wind and unpredictable
weather conditions all to give tourists
that one spectacular view sometimes it
is very scary you try not to let the
fear overcome you so you control the
aircraft you get it back to a safe
environment so you go home at night
that's the name of the game go home
[Music]
[Music]
my name is stanley snapkowski i've been
flying over niagara falls about 20 years
and each day is different
i spent 20 years in the military i've
flown in germany england vietnam
and the weather here is nothing like
anything else
[Music]
[Music]
niagara falls is beautiful but like
anything beautiful there's a ugly side
to it the weather here can change quite
rapidly you can have snow showers and
five minutes later you can have bright
sunny blue skies you have to have a
healthy respect for it because it can go
wrong in a matter of minutes the winds
can gust up to 30 to 40 miles an hour
when the wind comes around the buildings
it tends to create mechanical turbulence
either an updraft or downdraft or
swirling and then sometimes when you
make the turn into the wind it's almost
sometimes like hitting a brick wall i've
had instances where the aircraft wanted
to come apart quit flying and we nursed
it down the ground we got down and we
walked away and it could have ended up
differently without the training without
the knowledge
[Music]
as the only pilot on board the aircraft
if something happens it's my
responsibility to get everybody down
safely
i don't like being scared in the
helicopter i'm not a thrill seeker i
don't take a lot of unnecessary chances
i have a skill i have knowledge i know
my aircraft
and i know my capabilities and i try not
to exceed those
i sometimes think that mother nature is
not my friend today because of the winds
or because of the rain or snow you deal
with that you hopefully come out on a
good end or the other thing is you just
sit there and say okay you win today i'm
not going to fly
[Music]
i
look at the falls and i see the beauty
of nature some days is after a major
storm comes through
the air is so clear
you have maybe 100 miles visibility
and it's just awe inspiring to be able
to see all that and
see the falls from a different angle i
just love it
[Music]
there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city
people culture
late night food
but there's something missing
it's there but you can't see it
the night sky
[Music]
this is the story about a small town in
colorado
actually two small towns in colorado
that are devoted to space
westcliff has a population of 564
residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575.
this used to be a mining community and
then it evolved into a railroad
community and then into a ranching
community
we're always looking to do something
that will bring people into our
community and lately that seems to be we
need to invest in our sky
so they made light pollution their enemy
they darken their towns so that the
night sky could become their star
attraction
have you ever seen the milky way that
goes from horizon to horizon
88 of the world's population has never
seen the milky way it's the most
magnificent thing in the world that's
what we see here
but for the towns to go dark they needed
to cover all of their lights
not just street lamps but the lights
outside every house and ranch near town
that wasn't easy this is a frontier town
and i can tell you
frontier people don't like being told
what to do
we had to win their hearts and minds
it took 10 years
they passed ordinances raised money to
cover the street lights and even built
an observatory
the darker the town became the more
people saw the light
in 2016 the valley's dark sky was
designated as one of the darkest in the
world drawing visitors from all over
[Music]
that some other time you got the wrench
to do
okay
might need a six-pack though
well i was really hoping we'd be able to
see saturn by now yeah me too
that a community would decide to
dim its lights and help everyone to
appreciate the beauty of the night sky
is an amazing thing
[Music]
you come to a place like this
and
the stars just
burst
and it's remarkable
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
see the dark sky as our ancestors saw it
and i feel that we're a very special
place to be able to look at the stars as
people did thousands of years ago
it's a humbling thing suddenly you
realize you can almost touch it and
you're now a part of the bigger universe
and so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies that's what we're
trying to preserve
you